I should think that if people
were to get the wrong impression of me,
the one to which you
so eloquently referred,
it wouldn't be the wrong
impression in the slightest.
- That is me! That’s me there!
That's me.
Don’t you have someone’s
laundry to do?
Shouldn't you be at a
hairdressing convention?
- Ah!
- Sir.
My girlfriends say you
guys don't like women.
I'm just asking,
is there a place for us in all this,
or are you all scared of girls?
Honey, we think you're a lesbian.
- Gay iconography.
I myself
was once a gay.
Now I'm an ex-gay Megan.
May I have a kiss?
- Of course.
Alright.
One drink.
What would you like?
- Beer
- Beer?
Of course.
You don't have to bend the whole world.
I think it's better to just enjoy it.
If you shoot an arrow
and it goes real high
Hooray for you.
Don’t worry.
Let go.
You get to exhale now, Simon.
You get to be more
you than you have been in...
in a very long time.
And I'll say one more thing.
It'll clear the air.
I may have come close,
but I never had with you two have.